[Music]
we all know that Barack Obama loves
talking to your kids with big parenting
the Obama song are we ready okay and
that's all fine and dandy but now the
president wants your children to spend
less time at home and more time in
federally funded schools learning is fun
isn't it buddy
don't you just wish that you could learn
forever well that's great because from
now on you'll be in school for 33%
longer yeah that's right kids
forget about curling up with your mom
and a glass of chocolate milk after
school because he'll be too busy for a
childhood see Obama wants to lengthen
your school days and shorten your summer
vacations with the United States school
system ranking 25th out of a 40 tested
what makes Obama think that more time
spent in our subpar schools will make
the kids any smarter there's more of a
crap product make it any less crappy
these kids don't want to be here any
longer they don't even learn anything
all you do is sing songs and eat honey
all day seriously why are American
schools doing so poorly it certainly
isn't from a lack of funding spending on
education has increased by over 100
percent since 1971 where's graduation
rates and test scores are still pretty
much the same see in the American public
schooling system there's no school
choice and when there's no school choice
the kids have to take which ever school
they're dealt and there's nothing they
can do about it which is why many
conservatives support implementing about
your program that means that instead of
dumping an average of 92 hundred per
student into a government designated
school
attach the money to the child so they
can take it to the school of their
choosing but liberals don't like that
idea so don't you see friends school
choice is a bad thing option see
liberals are against it because they say
it would hurt the underprivileged
children after all private schools and
wealthier areas are better so most kids
would choose to go there see you little
buddies school choice but allow kids to
take their vouchers why shouldn't he get
to choose better schools - I'm still not
seeing how eliminating choice from the
equation for less affluent children is a
good thing look at Belgium or Denmark
they have a voucher program and their
students are light years beyond ours the
truth is that very few parents are
against school choice that's not to say
that it's without its opponents but
friends if we were to use vouchers some
teachers would lose their job security
yes the unions few people on the planet
have a kind of job security that members
of the teachers unions enjoy even if
they're terrible at their job they're
nearly impossible to fire after all
school should be about teachers and
lawyers not parents or students I don't
know it could just be me which is why I
want you to tell me how you feel about
school choice is it a good thing or
should we pump more money into our
current school system as always be sure
to let me know below
no don't do it we sensible about this